hi guys so I'm currently surrounded by
bags because I'm moving house and what
better way to celebrate that than to
play a horror game I've been am seeing
this lacking game around for a while now
I did see it on gamejolt a while back
cause I'm here maybe I'll play it
because it's a sound based horror game
and that kind of remind me a blindside
now's ok maybe I like it and then I
realized that loads of big people like p
but that's not playing it so you guys
probably already know what it is more
than I do because I haven't seen anyone
else there yet so let's see how it is
mad oh it's super sensitive hmm so I'm
like a back with my stomach cheering did
I miss something they got miss something
q nothing happens when I press cute I'm
pressing it q oh ho derpy derp q sis
audio logs press e there is 50 april
nineteen eighty six ET ce o-- thirteen
hundred dollars this is it moving into
human trials and gives us work it will
be greatest achievement morris on seven
and yet everyone will finally do mine
yet the operation on this subject zero
one will commence in two hours time
subject years in optimal condition it
returns to report from the assistance i
would like to go on record to say that I
observed no abnormal behavior from and
subject at all
oh hey aha Oh get a quick little face
going on there yeah let me just adjust
okay that's much better but
what if it is what is given to write the
variation was great success little one
still out cold but he expecting to wake
up it was a minor incipient however the
lab did have somehow managed to escape
the confines and we need to find it we
try to capture them I can't jump okay so
still bad nope he'll be gone oh my God
where did he go 00
hide in the glove it Nick not an option
oh so I am I'm looking at human bat
without wings not as cool what is this
what is that what are you what are you
doing why are you read what are you
doing oh my god what that why add
thought I was safe I buzzed to give the
kid again through pause but obviously it
could answer stupid I don't know it's
obviously not human whatever it's like
jasmine stay away from the bloody bars
do what normal people do and just walk
away from it oh so I just where am I
going what you get out
look I just went this way what am i
doing okay oh my god and Picabo that's
so creepy
what's for here I know this is proving
difficult without mouse I've packed most
of my stuff away this was a last minute
decision to make it video I was just
like board in put it in the bin whoa oh
here's a mouse that's what I need I need
a mouse ah look where my bin when way
okay let me see if I can get it in the
bin ah so close so close yet so far okay
so let's get out there
Oh way not listening to you I'm not
listening I'm not listening what was it
I'm not here I'm not here under them
something from the little rascals did
any of you watch The Little Rascals cuz
I even uh forget the foxes hey maybe I'd
kill you I'm really confused it's only
been like what ten minutes oh this way
don't be dirty oh I'm so stupid then
what excuse me would you say
what did you say to me oh oh you still
that okay uh [ __ ] scare me please leave
me alone oh I shifted my you gonna show
me that earlier I think I'm gonna
struggle without my mouth oh well it's
all part of the fun where the bloody
hell I you're underneath me no no it's
fine my big girl I didn't handle this
Pete no it's just cuz it's like right in
your ear as well and I think I can hear
him walking or is that just me ah
No
what no nothing is that funny not funny
what is funny oh my god i'm spitting
answers oh my god where is he in there
okay wait can I please pick you up thank
you for not making up yeah what what's
wrong I'm not sure oh he's eating people
I'm sure that's not you will make a man
who likes to play peek-a-boos we thought
okay ah yeah I don't want to go that way
Oh tail no don't let it go that way stop
what's this happening what is happening
what is happening what is happening I
don't know but what sorry right people
in the house I feel so uncomfortable
about this right shuffle shuffle is he
now bouncing on them oh no he's not read
though so does he just go read when he's
angry otherwise he kidding what was that
uh okay right this is going to confront
him yeah why not he seems like a nice
guy I'm sure we could be best friends Oh
Oh open the door please I'm here to help
I don't I places like this agent not
right places like this what the bloody
hell yeah I gotta calm down people in
this household don't play our games I
don't understand why people would just
scream for no reason ok let's try again
but this time let's just keep going
straight what did it I think I got to
the point us with severe though no no
what are you come from he's into me I
don't like it when people do that don't
think anyone okay let's just try going
straight down across time here don't
forget shift yasmin shift to run shift
around
can't what am I supposed to do I don't
even do-do-do-do-do do-do-do-do-do
do-do-do-do-do do-do-do-do-do the dude
oh yes it worked that never works yes
succeed okay I knew it my wife that will
show them now those fools will have to
wait is that him is the dying boy dr.
person okay so i found this but it
appears i don't need it i was supposed
to go somewhere else no
go throw something in house you come to
me so quickly what am i suppose the day
all right w shift let's go for this
you're watching from the doors hey I
can't run away from him he's too fast
gonna see if he's hungry for a burger am
I don't think that's what this is but
whatever i'm saying that it is oh god it
worked kind of okay jasmine don't pick
it up pick it up of Jesus
get up yeah screw it right I tried
enough times I'm sorry I'm going to give
up um let me know if you want me to
carry on with a mouse and that might
make some sort of difference probably
will so yeah let me know if you're I
carry on I hope you enjoy that it was
pretty freaky um it's just a weird
concept but it's really cool and
different I like all these weird stuff
coming out it's good if it sums up if
you liked it and had a lovely day or
evening by do i put the eyes okay I want
you oh my god that's creepy don't go far
I